[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back we're at the fox nation
patriot awards in hollywood florida we
are all in on fox nation
and not just because they throw great
parties and they're nice people we're
all in on fox nation because it's
protected from
the tech monopolies that control almost
every part of american life but they
don't control fox nation subscription
service we can say whatever we want we
don't have to be afraid because they're
not pulling the strings and that's worth
a lot right now we think
here's an example by the way of what can
happen if you're not protected we pay is
the subsidiary of jpmorgan chase
recently we pay decided to deny payment
processing conservatives services to a
major conservative group group in
missouri a group called the defense of
liberty
we pay claimed the group was involved in
quote hate violence racial intolerance
and terrorism
were they
no
scott fitzpatrick is the state treasurer
of missouri he's demanding evidence
those accusations are true so far we pay
has not provided it scott fitzpatrick
joins us now to explain the superpower
thank you so much for coming on tonight
and thank you for being one of the very
few elected officials to do anything
about this um
is this a violation of law do you
believe
well i think chase has the uh i guess
the right to do whatever they want in
terms of who they do business with but
in terms of who we as the state of
missouri are going to do business with
we won't be doing business with any bank
in the state treasurer's office that
chooses to discriminate against
essentially half the population the
conservative half of half the population
and they decided to do this they
suspended the defense of liberty whose
founder is a guy named paul kurtman
who's a marine corps veteran that
deployed to the middle east and fought
in the war on terror and then came back
to missouri and was a state
representative that i served with for
for six years is a great limited
government free market conservative who
brings these uh these events together
the the speaker at this next event that
they we're going to have that we pay
essentially canceled and is causing to
be rescheduled was going to be donald
trump jr and cecilia johnson who's the
director of black engagement for the rnc
and like you said they've essentially
accused them of of being a hate
organization a racist organization with
no evidence and they also said that
their decision-making process is
proprietary and therefore no additional
information could be given to them but
that the decision was final and so i
sent a letter today to jamie dimon who's
as you know the ceo of jpmorgan chase
essentially told them that as long as
they're going to discriminate
against half the country and frankly
what's about 60 of missourians according
to the last election and not do business
with with conservative organizations uh
that they're not going to be eligible to
do business with the state of missouri
amen really quick last week in new york
a leader of the black lives matter
organization threatened violence against
the sitting mayor of new york if he
dared to enforce the law in new york
are they still a client of jpmorgan
chase were they d platform too do you
know black lives matter
yeah i don't think that they i don't
think that they've de-platformed them
they're only interested in
de-platforming conservatives and if
they're only interested in doing
business with one half of the of the
country they can change their name to
woke bank or snowflake bank or something
so we'll see how it goes though
scott fitzpatrick i appreciate you
coming on thank you
thanks for having me
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else